-I have a question.
What's that
little door back there?
Is that where you keep
your troll people?
-Yeah, we have --
Well, that's -- those are --
those are
the troll people there.
And then, those are --
What's slightly larger
than a troll?
A hobbit?
An ogre, I guess, yeah.
-A hobbit's
smaller than a troll, right?
We established that
from "Lord of the Rings"?
-Yeah, hobbits are small.
-Yeah.
I mean, you would know, right?
Would you know?
I don't know.
Do you like those films?
-I would know.
I watched those films.
-[ Laughs ]
-Listen, uh, I feel like
you're stereotyping me.
However, the problem is,
you are accurate, so...
-You did --
I want to bring it up,
because you broke free of
your own stereotype recently
Now, in the beginning,
you played into the stereotype
You got cast in a Marvel
project, "The Eternals."
That's very much in line wit
what we'd expect from Kumail
I remember once seeing you d
stand-up comedy
in the basement
of a comic-book store.
All of that tracked.
-Mm-hmm.
-Then you got in, like,
super comic-book shape,
and that was, I think,
where you diverged
from what we knew
and expected of Kumail.
-To be sincere, I was like
so they asked me
to play a superhero thing,
and I was --
and my first thought was,
"My God. I can't believe
this is happening."
Second thought was, "[Bleep]
I have to now get in shape."
Because it was important to me
because I was the first, like,
Pakistani superhero, like,
in a mainstream Hollywood movie,
in a Marvel movie.
I was like, "I want to look like
somebody who can, like,
hang with Thor and
Captain America," you know
I didn't want to, like...
-Yeah.
-...also be the first
schlubby superhero.
Like, I just wanted
to break one barrier.
I didn't want to break
all of the barriers.
-Right.
-And I think that's a vali
and valuable barrier to break.
It's for somebody else,
not for me.
So that's why
I sort of was like, "All right
I have to really,
really do this."
You know what sucks about it is,
there was no, like,
secret to it, you know?
It just was -- it was like
"Oh, if I had done this
when I was 21,
I would have looked like thi
for most of my life,
and it would've been
way easier to achieve.
How different
would everything have been?"
Emily did say -- She --
You know, it was --
This transformation was hard for
me, but it was harder for Emily.
I definitely became,
like, 30% less interesting
but I think it's a fair trade.
[ Both laugh ]
-You -- We had Issa Rae on
this week,
talking about "The Lovebirds."
This is a film where you guy
play a couple going throug
some tough times, and you ge
framed for murder.
You filmed it in New Orleans
And she was talking about,
it was nice to be a woman
on a film set
who was co-starring with a man
who were both thinking about
what they were eating.
But I realize now,
both of you,
having to think about it,
in New Orleans,
a city known for its food,
was it extra hard?
-Yeah.
I mean, it's impossible.
Everything is, like, delicious
and deep-fried, you know?
It's, uh --
It was really --
You know what I did?
I just didn't eat it.
I never even tried it.
Like, people would be like
"You can just one day just try
this food, you have to,"
and I was like,
"I'll make another trip out.
I didn't have one beignet,
you know?
I was like, "If I have one
then I know what I'm missing
If I don't go there
and just stick to my
awful protein shakes
and protein bars..."
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, in the beginning,
when I started having
protein shakes, I was like
"This isn't so bad."
And now I'm a year and a hal
in, I'm like,
"This tastes like hot vomit.
[ Both laugh ]
-You get -- You get kicked
by a horse in the film --
not a real horse, but a
real horse with a rubber leg
Is this true?
-Well, there was a real horse.
And, you know, we --
We didn't get to --
That scene took a long time,
so the horse kind of
had to wait.
Like, the horse waited,
like, three extra days.
I could tell the horse
was a little like,
"Come on, guys.
I'm a [bleep] horse."
Sorry, I shouldn't swear.
[ Both laugh ]
He's like, "I'm a horse.
Don't make me wait.
I'm a horse."
And it was weird.
You'd just be sitting there,
waiting to shoot the scene
and you look over,
and by craft services,
there's a horse.
There's, like, a horse there
Like, he was in our space.
The horse
didn't have his own trailer.
He would actually
have a trailer trailer.
So -- But we filmed it so that
when I actually got kicked
you know, it's an actual -
like, a very realistic rubber --
just the leg of a horse,
which is much more disturbin
than a horse.
Like, if you're walking down
the street, what's worse?
You see a horse, or you se
just the leg of a horse?
-Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, I guess you would thin
you would have a better chance
of getting away
from a solitary leg.
-If it's just
the leg of a horse,
and it's moving, two things.
One, you will get away.
Two, your world
is now different.
-It's very exciting
to see you and Issa together
I've been fans of you both
for a really long time.
The movie is great.
And thank you so much, Kumail.
It's always so nice
to talk to you,
and thanks
for making us some time.
-Thanks for having me, man
Thank you.
-All right, we'll see you soon